of course I'm tough but I'm smart too
I'm more smart than tough
what we ready for the motivation watch
it's half ten with believe nation
what's that believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a man who went
from growing up in Russia studying
martial arts as a child
and wrestling with a bear at age nine as
a part of his training to becoming the
undisputed UFC lightweight champion he's
kebede the Margaux Medoff and here's my
take on his top ten rules of success
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be confident culinary's Bacon aim I
have big name you know and this is very
good for paper I'm confident you know
when I watch his eyes I don't feel
nothing he's like drunk guy you know
he's like drunk I feel he's like his
face is like like this you know in
nervous he drunk and he little bit white
you know it's like when you say to Danny
no no I'm not gonna touch him I wanna
watch his eyes and I think I'm here and
I watch his eyes I feel nothing I swear
to God I feel like he nervous he drunk
how we're gonna fight with me with me 25
minute this is not Nate Diaz or this is
not Eddie Alvarez or Josie hell that
this is a completely different fighter
you know if we're not stop it you have
to kill me
this guy have to him if I see him if I
keep seeing I'm gonna keep going I'm
gonna keep go forward
don't rush stay relaxed you know give
him very good
you know like crazy time inside the cage
rule number two always be prepared you
know like if you cannot beat anyone in
this division like max Holloway the
acquaintance or 20 Ferguson you know
like you make wait you already do very
good training camp you ready
and now if you're gonna talk about all
these guys difference at least the guy
you know I need like couple month for
training for this guy how you can call
yourself champion if you're champion if
you wanna be champion undisputed
undefeated you have to come compete
anybody today's our mother still Ramadan
day you know today were fasting so now
I was like 5 p.m. almost and after two
and a half hour we're gonna eat
who can it
today this today is Sunday - you know we
come here like almost like ten people
resting each other you know and it's
very important very important stay ready
stay in shape you know because anytime
you can call me and say hey you gotta
fight to a month three months and that's
why I have to be they have to stay ready
rule number three be smart so if the
shoes on the other foot if the roles
were reversed you wouldn't take this
fight on six days notice you think it's
crazy for him to do this for me I never
take this no why why anything this fight
I need eight weeks trying hard last one
week make weight and go to the world
because when I go to the world I have to
know hey I'm ready or no because like
six days you cannot be you cannot
training you have to cut weight all six
days you know and this is not about oh
and tough I'm gonna show you guys how
I'm tough
of course I'm tough but I'm smart too
I'm more smart than tough and people
watching my record and they think oh
this guy tough this is not about that
this is about mine this is about how you
think when you fight like you know like
this is about everything you know why I
need take some fight like if you have to
give me fight I try no injures come here
make weight fight but other stuff I
don't care like if your self problem
this is UFC problem this is that's why
my name is Habib other name is you see
you know I care about my legacy
UFC already have his legacy know like
UFC is the biggest organization right
now in the world like it's gonna be
without you see or know people gonna
remember this like I want people
remember my name like undisputed
undefeated you see lightweight champion
and why I need take like six days before
fight like some fights I never do this
rule number four play your game he's
talked about your brother he's called
your father a coward he has made fun of
where you live are you going into this
fight angry at all mmm
David
I can control my emotional you know he
can he can say worry what he want you
know like when some hog alcohol you guys
talking about something people don't
care about this I don't care about worry
talking about because I know who I am
I know my friends so my family know my
clothes people know who I am and one
hundred said I'm sure he knows too but
he just want to make me nervous but it's
okay this is part of the his game and of
course I'm a little bit angry but you
have to control your emotional you know
when I go to the cage I'm gonna control
and I have planned
don't rush stay relaxed go forward and
make him tired after I can do whatever I
want
rule number five work hard I feel I have
energy I feel I have to improve
something and that's why we come here
we sent a nice message each other hey
let's go tomorrow 3:00 p.m. we have to
Train we have to Train everybody and
some people say I'm tired today is
Sunday today is race day but some people
say okay we're gonna come because we
have somebody have fight after one month
somebody have fight after one and a half
month and you know that's why everybody
we have to turn if you fight please come
to come Jimmy train and only hard work
you know we have only one way it's like
you can't wait
I remember all the time come from here
running and sprint here ten times and go
back to running its take like maybe 25
30 minute every day before I go to
school I do this training running here
sprint to this mountain and go back home
drills home resting drills a little bit
lifting and go to the school
it's my like every day I do this and all
the time when I come to village I turn
there all the time come here
running around Tama do sprints rule
number six be a good role model what I
don't like when too much people know yes
because too many young
young guys like polo oz follow him
and I can I don't want to be a bad
example for young generation I do want
this I do understand you know we cannot
be bad people for young generation
people of course you try to promote this
fight make honey yeah but like end of
the day you have to think about the
young generation age too many people
watch on us and you know
and to be a role model we really should
just be saying I don't talk about him I
know I wanna talk about me
okay I wanna be good one but I know it's
very hard
nobody's perfect
rule number seven surround yourself with
greatness
I've not thought these guys like one
year two years Turner's I know this has
more than 15 years
no we stay together like science when
I'm beginning my amateur career where
everybody be here with my father and you
know it's like my brother's my friends
like oh here files you know we keep
training with you competition always
like this I don't have a lot I don't
like this
I'm little bit scared about this you
know they're alone we are not like
because like when you're living you need
someone with you always
if you make mistake they have to say hey
you make mistake you have to become
a different way
like wherever that is women and
everybody make mistake this way Allah
say hey you guys have to be always
together like drama you know it's very
important this is not my French friend
listen listen about five
[Applause]
rule number eight be respectful what
caused you to to jump over the cage and
indigo after Connors team it's off guys
how are you
first of all I want to say sorry to
athletic commission Nevada sorry to
Vegas I know this is not my best side
you know this is not my best side you
know I'm humor bin and like I know
understand how people can talk about I
jump on the cage you know what about he
talk about my religion he talk about my
country he talk about my father he come
to Brooklyn and he broke bass he almost
killed couple people worried about this
worried about this why people talk about
I jump over the cage why people still
talk about this like I don't understand
I am respect my father teach me hey you
have to be always respectful my old team
where I'm training California seven
years everybody know who I am
media a little bit change MMA this is a
respect sport you know this is not
trash-talking sport
this is recipe so like I told you before
guys I wanna change this game I don't
wanna people talk about like opponents
talk about his father like like religion
you you cannot talk about religion you
cannot take about nation you know guys
you cannot talk about this stuff and you
know this is for me is very important
rule number nine help others like in
there
say hands habit I control this
everything here you have to give me
money you said this small guy it's very
small guy I tell me what you control
like about parking like everything and
he's like 10 years old his ears like
smash like crazy you know like if he
looked like he training right here he
hewed he resting like last 20 years you
know he said please you have to give me
money because I control everything now
you come here you park your car you have
to pay me money I go crazy with it I
live like crazy I said okay how how much
I have to give it's like $10 you know I
said you too expensive you have to be
come down like maybe five six dollars my
10 goes too much for you they say hey my
mother is sick you have to pay me I said
okay I'm gonna tell you it's great
Dagestan like mother Dagestan life and
rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is wrestle with
bears
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I've got a special bonus clip around how
to stay humble that I think you're gonna
really enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing question
it's time to move from just watching
another video to actually taking action
in your life or your business and if
you're feeling bold answer these
questions in the comments below here we
go number one
how can you surround yourself with
greatness number two what's the thing
that helps you feel the most confident
and number three how can you start your
day every day with it
never know what's gonna happen tomorrow
and you have to stay loyal all the time
with your team with your coaches with
your like with everybody who close with
you you know
sometimes like when you win belt with
the belt coming like a lot of attention
a lot of money like like crazy stuff a
lot of crazy stuff and I don't want this
bill change me you know I want to stay
focused
I wanna after Ramadan beginning training
and come back this year and they fed
this title you know like I'm a little
bit worried about this belt because
sometimes you think all now like your
UFC champion like lot of stuff but I'm a
little bit scared about this
I don't wanna change I want to be same
habit like before built and after belt
and this is not about me this is about
all people around me raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
that people need passion and not one
drop of my self-worth depends on your
it's supposed to mean
if you like this video check at the top
10 I did on Conor McGregor I think
you'll like it the link is right there
next to me continue to believe and I'll
see you there this is what gives me
energy
saying I'm gonna do something say it
putting it out there for the world to
see
I mean don't out doing it